one of the most common questions I am
told is Felix how do you remain so
humble and I gotta say being the most
successful youtuber of all time having
the most views of all time being this
attractive being this charismatic being
this all-around wonderful being that
everyone just loves it's not easy to
remain this humble but what I do is I
look at other humble people and I
appreciate their humbleness and that
inspires me to become even more humble
I'm actually not just humble I'm Way
more humble than I think you could even
understand so let's explore some other
humble people that we can find
inspiration from together the agony of
being too beautiful to stay faithful oh
this one hits close to home I I am
extremely attractive it's just a pain
it's not just a pain it is an agony one
woman's very brave confession incredible
absolutely this this I feel this one
alright let's click on the next video up
[Music]
how is what is this doing here
oh that times magazine hundred most
influential people Felix Kjellberg
article written by none other than Trey
Parker himself I can't believe this just
popped up there don't want to brag but
my Nick bird is looking ok today this is
so typical of so many youtubers their
ego has to spool own out of proportion
that they don't realize when they're not
being humble absolutely disgusting
behavior from jacksFilms and I expect
nothing less from him to be honest I get
it
I'm not a celebrity I just have over two
billion views online and get approached
by people every time I go out in public
yeah that's right stop calling me a
celebrity I can barely leave the door
without the swarm of paparazzi and fans
meeting
than right please step aside I am just
the mayor human trying to walk along you
stop calling me a celebrity because I am
NOT never changed on easy on the new
pope is a humble man very much like me
which is which probably explains why I
like him so much I understand this one
humble beings get attracted to other
humble character that's this simple
science fact
if you're not humble then you probably
can't understand this you're not known
to be a humble man but I wonder I think
I am actually humble I think I'm much
more humble than you would understand
well this clip he's so awesome that's an
example of a humble man
no one likes someone that pranks
constantly see no one likes you kill ill
kid no one cares about how many
subscribers you have stop bragging about
your 450 subscribers did I mention that
I have 62 million by the way Oh what is
this the most handsome faces of 2017 oh
I forgot this tab open oh sorry guys I
was doing some research on humble people
and this showed up not my intention
I'm on a walk and sis guys keep checking
me out oh all these boys just keep
looking at me
ah just don't you just hate when that
happens
especially sis Kai's absolute worst is
it just me or does this paid off 2016
Ranger uber make my new haircut look
good a very nice combination of being
humble about your haircut and your new
vehicle at once
very inspiring self oh it keeps going
I've been doing this thing lately where
I tip people obscenely and give money to
all the homeless people I see literal
Saint here guys what a humble character
love is when your seven-year-old knocks
your Woman of the Year Award off the
shelf did I mention that I was Woman of
the Year
I wore it by the way smashes it and you
scoop him up and tell him it's fine
because the work you did to get that
award is still out there in the world
and I don't need a big bronze eagle with
my name on it people already know
especially thanks to tweets like this
one when I have a drawer full of letters
from readers
lives have changed instead he's more
distraught than I am I'm so glad they
gave woman of the year to such a humble
character that doesn't like to brag or
at least humble brag a homeless woman
asked me to buy her water so I did two
of the best brands Wow literal Saint the
best brands of water for a homeless
person don't you think you that's a
little too far don't you think that's
spending money a bit too carelessly when
I exited Whole Foods then I mentioned I
shop food at Whole Foods I asked her to
choose which bottle which which bottle
of what are you I did this action to
remind myself that no matter what
situation we are in we always have a
choice
humbleness is incredible
this is all about the second thing I
wanted to address in this video is the
comments of me being a rich kid I'm
gonna go ahead and address you guys
right now that is not the case that is
not the case with this channel you know
you guys might be on the wrong channel
if you think then that I'm a rich kid of
some sort I'm just trying to address
that guys I just had worked very hard
for what I've got on my channel and I
take that with pride and joy and the
last thing is extremely humble
characters I just love how YouTube
especially just breeds humble character
it's it's a community just filled with
people that don't want to show off too
much it's not like it just rewards the
whole channel by putting money in the
title which creates a wonderful
ecosystem of just humble characters such
as me I am so happy I gave up a
scholarship to get my masters to become
a youtuber it was required it would have
given me a high-paid job and I didn't
I'm so glad I decided to go with what I
love I never felt more alive it's not
every day that you have a dragonfly land
on your finger when you're washing your
car you must know I donate a lot of
money to these environmental groups by
the way did I tell you a classic example
of how to be humble this completely
unrelated thing happened so this gives
me a chance to be humble about what I am
so great I see a reoccurring pattern
here sure they can't call sure they tell
me I'm pretty sure my outfits are great
sure they tell me that my art can save
the world
but does any of it mean anything do they
see the struggles and victories of an
artist a thinker
behind closed doors anymore
I think the same thing all the time
yes I have an extremely attractive
persona and face but is anyone really
serious
I have also extremely amount of
intellects collected in here does anyone
even see that number one rule of being
humble this said giving through the
homeless wholly counts if you're filming
it otherwise who's gonna know about it
even with 140 IQ did I mention that my
IQ is hundred and forty I still can't
install a printer even with 105 thousand
IQ I'm still just a dummy like you guys
even though I am incredibly smart I am
still just a dummy damn AVG protected
you from several threats recently AVG
antivirus software of all time
[Music]
this is the national anthem for humble
characters such as myself and JP my
favorite part of the event hey you have
an interview in ten minutes
me sorry I'll be signing stuff and
taking photos until I have met everyone
[Music]
I was in the kitchen with me